any thoughts on the future of filmmaking
for the next 5 10 15 years well I see it
some much more interactive than it ever
was before and once were you to be than
ever was before and much more like
people sitting around the fire you know
in the darkness telling stories to
another than it was before become less
professional are more authentic or real
I guess I really am a kind of
independent film guy the movies I really
love our movies that did at one time or
another attempt to sort of their
personal witness to the world little
movable little fugitive other than if
you were sought 1952 Mars angle goes out
on the beach in Coney Island and doesn't
movie about a little boy who thinks he
shot his brother horses not true and so
he spends a weekend on the beach in
Coney Island amorous angles out there
with a handmade camera um with the
silent camera was they dubbed finally
and it's a living authentic film so I'm
hoping that will move in that direction
whether or not happens I don't know but
I think it might not with welcome it if
it does it just as the fear you spoke of
in 1895 you're telling me I've manager
froze on camera off that about the train
coming toward the audience and people
never seeing something like this and
thought it was real what fears do you
see people have now about this new media
and maybe they're valid maybe it's just
fear of change well I think everybody
feels things are getting out of control
and that it's very difficult to figure
your way through this thicket of new
media and new opportunities new
opportunities are also sort of confusing
because the career paths are not as
simple and obvious as they were before
so that's you know that's frightening I
think two people but there's enormous
possibility I think we'll get through
this stuff I think it'll work I'm
optimistic about but for the moment
we're just running around
trying to fit around our way
you